BuzzFeed news announces shutdown some
staff members will be offered jobs at
Huffington Post which CEO Jonah Peretti
said is less dependent on social
platforms uh and then I guess our news
team decided a picture of BuzzFeed on
fire was the appropriate solid solid
thumbnail
I'm kind of thinking like that was your
last imagine that was your last
assignment
that is I
you tell the end of the day if you don't
mind yeah I'm actually impressed with
our news team for deciding that's the
picture to use what is that photo even
of it's like from a 90s movie and
there's like an office draft maybe yeah
speaking of it's like and as BuzzFeed is
being burned off the wall is that AI
develop that thumbnail uh partially so
it's like putting together a bunch of
different that's what happened well
basic was it like a month ago that they
were kind of like Hey we're gonna have
ai replacing most of our Riders at
BuzzFeed and the stock kind of jumped
because people were pretty pumped about
it it didn't put one dollar to like a
dollar ten well what's happening
now it's back down below companies are
doing Mass layoffs if you guys have been
following there's like uh David was
talking like the bottom 10 of all these
corporations are getting cut but they're
keeping wage they're keeping prices and
sales the same so their stocks going up
companies stocks are rising right now
stockholders are very happy that's part
of when you do you know low-level
layoffs I don't know what it comes they
did like 40 reverse mergers too do you
see the company I think it was Hermes or
something and it was it was like some
super luxury brand and their CEO this
woman was like got a four million dollar
bonus and they didn't give any bonuses
this year yeah she was giving them this
like speech about like suck it up okay
sometimes you know you don't get your
bonus or whatever and she's doing the
zoom call and she's like I'm just sick
of people and all you're crying and all
this stuff she got killed the uh the
well journalism got really mad
making fun of them so it's a bit more um
what's what's the word I'm looking for
it's more of a desecration of this the
spirit of BuzzFeed I called I called I
called them racist which is like in
their in their world that's like whoa
gloves are off you know insults that's
their AdWords
they own complex yeah no let me tell you
BuzzFeed News ran a story where they
claimed a black man was killed fighting
over a fried chicken sandwich
did you guys ever hear that story no
I've seen that story no so uh when the
Popeye's chicken sandwich thing was
going on and the media was claiming that
everybody was fighting for sandwiches
BuzzFeed News ran a fake story claiming
that two guys fought to the death over a
fried chicken sandwich and when I
reached out to BuzzFeed news and said
guys the story is not real like check
your sources they basically told me to
go screw myself they were going to keep
keep the story up you ever want to work
in this industry well they probably like
you know well this is performing want us
to delete this thing yup that's exactly
what it is it look BuzzFeed runs
headline of black man murdered fighting
over Fried Chicken Sandwich they're
getting tons of hits and they don't care
who they're getting it from A View From
a white supremacist and A View From A
leftist is to say it's a number for an
Advertiser boom yeah so when I told the
Editor in Chief like this is not true
his attitude is kind of like so what
this is true that they want to Pulitzer
Prize oh probably a bunch of them oh
surprises are handing out like Cracker
jackets
no he was doodling on a napkin and the
guy just came up
is that original
oh my God that's the best 10 best 10
list I've ever seen yeah that's the
majority of what they do they were like
popular for is the the you know 10
things that you know technical yeah but
that's BuzzFeed I know buzzfeed's still
cooking and they're and a lot of the
news people are gonna start to funnel
into like Huffington Post and some of
these other places
they're gonna get I warned that they'll
get increasingly more unhinged so I said
this back in 2018 BuzzFeed or BuzzFeed
news all of them yeah just because they
don't have their secret sauce of trump
well well that's true too but because
they're view because their viewership is
dependent upon escalation as time goes
on they have to keep being crazier and
crazier to keep someone's attention
right like if a dude goes outside of
your house and he dresses like Hillary
Clinton with clown makeup on yeah and
juggles a bunch of bowling pins you're
gonna look out your window and you're
gonna be like guys everybody come look
at this thing wait do you live near me
in Brooklyn but the next day because
that guy lives right outside right and
you're not watching him right now that's
right the next day you go oh the guy's
out there again you don't care so he's
got to add a chicken to the mix you're
like hey the Hillary Clinton guy he's
got a chicken in there now so they have
to keep adding new weird especially
because they're not a destination like
if you you know if you run a show and
you have your core viewers sometimes it
might be up sometimes you go through
like phases yeah no one's like they
don't have a core group of people I
don't think that like oh let me check
out BuzzFeed news every morning oh yeah
just
like every morning out on the porch I
gotta check out my BuzzFeed you know but
they actually said this that they're
it's all about just the social media
algorithms that's their whole thing so
buzzfeed's whole BuzzFeed news was all
about producing shock content on social
media to capture people who don't
actually care about the brand
yeah of course yeah yeah yeah well that
that that's not going to work and so I
didn't know that they were going to go
they were going to implode I mean
BuzzFeed stock is at like 70 cents or
something from 10 bucks could you
imagine being stupid enough to have have
bought stock
actually who was uh our buddy Matt who
was actually trying to pump that for a
while he goes he's like I have a feeling
shout out to Matt I hope you're not
watching he's injured he's in journalism
and he saw the whole restriction because
I think this is like you want to bet on
this Pony right here
you want to bet on them to break their
leg so you buy put options and you would
have made yourself a fortune yeah yeah
no I mean there's especially in the last
two years like there's zero chance that
there ever like that they had their
Moment Like Trump coveted all the mix
right sure yeah their stocks started to
drop in December of 2020. it's not just
them it is like in some ways the whole
industry the shock it is
if you will political click pay and like
clicking uh chasing ad Revenue instead
of subscriber well their ad Revenue
thing is even crazier the stuff that
these places do because they basically
will be like you know they'll be selling
a million impressions and then they all
sort of like pool together it would be
like if Tim was like hey we sell this
many views and then came to us and all
these other people it was like hey can
you give me 40 views like they're like
they're uh like drug addicts being like
yeah yeah I know I just need I need
another 40 clicks and then Vice like
gives them views so you vital cell views
and then go to all these smaller places
and so you're like I bought Vice clicks
and then you go they really you get
these other clicks on all these random
ass places so the whole thing's like the
whole industry is like a glass house the
the BuzzFeed market cap is only 106
million dollars someone super chatted
Tim by BuzzFeed okay
send the super
I'm gonna be completely honest and I
think everyone's gonna agree buzzfeed's
in real tough shape they are struggling
but if it was me that took it over and
ran it yeah well then everybody knows
Buzz full I would shove it in the toilet
so fast and just completely gut it and
sell off all the all the resources and
property
laptops printers I'd Purge all of the
retirement funds button knife shirts
guys okay that was a funny joke but in
all seriousness if I bought BuzzFeed it
would become the most successful media
company in the world it would be the
highest we'd launch a show it would be
the highest rated show and it would be
called firing journalists and we live
stream every day when we when when we
have the journal assault in the office
here's the best part all the BuzzFeed
employees
you're allowed to keep your jobs but you
don't have to do any work we're just
going to film various live streams of
all of you sitting at your desks waiting
because you never know when we're gonna
call your name
I kind of think that's what they're
currently doing is right just sit there
pretending to work all day yes yes but
imagine this show where it's like you
see this you know Brook uh Brooklyn 30
year old hipster sitting there shaking
scared and then they're all just like
looking at each other and there's no
laptops they're not doing anything and
then all of a sudden basically your
chicken coop but there right but they
hear like the PA is like
the next person to be called in and
everyone's looking at each other shaking
and it's like John and then like two
guys look at each other like okay I'm a
John Smith
John Baldwin and then you know John
gotta give them all numbers you don't
even refer to them they don't get names
anymore they go uh employee number zero
zero one eight seven please uh come to
the office I think it'd be better if you
had to shoot like the sort of button
that they just go down but with the
shoes down the Chute you know yes it
would be fun too well then you have
cameras in the shoot yeah but maybe what
we do obviously have cameras in the
shoot when they come into the office
there's like a studio audience and then
like the host has a studio
the host has like a cane in the top hat
and then the audience gets to vote on
whether the person gets to keep their
job for the day based on their articles
yeah
I don't want him writing auditors
it would do really well I mean you could
like and you don't need the full money
right like you're you know when you yeah
you can Finance it yeah well actually I
I think mortgage BuzzFeed
um I think we could crowdfund purchase
BuzzFeed that's pretty funny 106 million
dollars dude yo it's expensive gag if I
could give you any advice I'd say wait
like six months I think you'll get it at
a steal from the 100 million for real I
bet you get it for 30 million in six
months from now that's the thing you do
right now is you go to them and say look
in six months buzzfeed's gonna be worth
50. change it to BuzzFeed nudes and then
kind of have like an only fan step
situation yeah I don't I honestly don't
see BuzzFeed as a whole company
surviving at all it's done no no they'll
go back like what kind of debt do they
have like they might be insolvent and
you just don't know like that right you
know what they own they own this a lot
of weird stuff though like if you go to
the airport they have like BuzzFeed like
convenience stores yeah
that's probably why they're different
they have their own brand of kitchen
utensils yeah so there's not just the
the news station right interesting
yeah like there's other assets on that
company I'm not gonna go anywhere near
buying stock from a company like this or
anything oh yeah I'd avoid that not
right now I mean their stocks down from
nine bucks to 75 cents in the last five
bucks to 75 cents in a year they own
Huffington Post and they own complex
networks it's complex as in like hot
ones that's crazy
that's something hot ones or something
that's something chicken wings people
like that's a property yeah I don't know
uh complex I don't know if that's the
same complex but maybe first you don't
know what complex is complex is like was
a hip-hop thing I know that's what and
that's where the hot ones is part of
yeah yeah I know that I'm saying I don't
know if it's the same complex Like This
Global youth Entertainment Network
unparalleled reach to Millennials I mean
this is what they're saying it is
pretty parallel pal we're not your
investors so it's paralleled what's
there what's their their market cap is
106 million I mean you could buy every
share right in the open market and oh
yeah you wouldn't even have to go make
like a private deal you could just buy
them right only if you have to it's hard
obviously if you wed did it then yes but
theoretically if you could buy them all
in one they're tangible asset value
according website was 300 million yeah
it's no it's not
and it looks like complex what is that
website buzzfeed.com it says like
complex networks is part of BuzzFeed Inc
and creates distributes programming to
Netflix Hulu course chorus TBS so like
it's not just the name BuzzFeed that has
value Productions yeah they for sure
have like infrastructure okay I I kind
of do want to buy it I mean it would be
like the greatest thing to buy it's like
buying a skin suit yeah yeah but just
like I'm just imagining all the blue
techie journalists sort of make not
anymore they wouldn't know blue Jackie
journalists anymore right but like
they're so mad at me because so I
tweeted out you know they're like oh but
this woman she tweeted buzzfeed's
shutting down because you know people
just don't want fair and accurate
reporting or whatever that's the reason
yeah and I was yeah right and I'm like
well Tim cast is is certified nearly
perfect certification from newsguard and
we're expanding so I don't know what
your what Your excuses what's buzzfeed's
excuse they got super angry that I'm
basically rubbing salt into the wound
yeah but it feels good yeah I mean I
imagine
you many times yeah that's they started
it a little bit I'm sure some of those
places have run some not so nice
articles right yeah hoping to post
actually I don't know where they're at
now but when I went to Sweden the oven
post actually wrote the most accurate
depiction of what happened in Sweden I
was actually surprised I used to love
them Ariana Huffington I thought she was
great in 2011. you used to read
Huffington Post I would see it because I
was working at mines when we were
starting mine so we'd be sourcing
stories from all over the place and that
was one of the places I'd find
relatively good stuff it used to be at
the beginning of it like it wasn't open
for girls right no it was started by a
woman it was like a normal news site
it's just Ariana Huffington started it
but it wasn't for girls it wasn't a
chick thing it wasn't like oh wait wait
hold on a minute like how come wait I
there's a bunch of billionaires out
there why don't they just buy
buzzfeeding because he's like because
they're smart and they know that it's
not worth anything it's like remember
what was in Myspace like we're talking
about it for 500 million dollars
let me just let me just tell you right
now right explain how it works you guys
when you have a company let's say let's
say you have a Colma an emerald mine in
South Africa or something and the total
value of that mind is a hundred million
dollars but the mine itself generates 10
million like a million dollars per month
or something
so the it's hard to determine
evaluations because everybody's got a
different idea of what something could
be worth well then everyone has a no
idea what it's going to be worth in the
future but I'll put it this way if you
own an emerald mine and you're getting a
million bucks a month so you're like
okay I need a hundred months so in 10
years you'd have enough money you
leverage it you take out a loan yeah but
this is in this scenario you own a lump
of mine yeah but here's my point if
I if I had an emerald mine that was
generating that much I would buy
BuzzFeed just to destroy it for the
betterment of mankind
I would put those debts
I'm telling you you intervening is not
going to help the downfall of BuzzFeed
just let them do their thing just wait
get that dimple stamp on it I'm sure it
probably won't make any difference to
the readers well there's a lot of
billionaires out there like that could
just buy BuzzFeed but you know because
imagine if Trump was like I'm gonna be
banging BuzzFeed and then I'm firing
everybody and shutting it down you have
to be able to spend that kind of money
for a prank like honestly
you want to drop 44 bill
right here this is the coffee budget
like seriously Elon Musk buy BuzzFeed is
100 million dollars chicken food that's
chunk change yeah it is yeah nothing so
what's elon's net worth right now 100
200 billion I think or it's still 200
billion I don't know I haven't checked
it it's a lot it's so we're talking
about 200 yeah
so Elon just needs to liquidate point
zero five percent of his net worth and
he can buy BuzzFeed he's got a lot of
liquidating lately though yes yeah but
you just press off you just no more
BuzzFeed yeah what about if he sends one
of those rockets and then when it comes
back down to earth has any hands on the
BuzzFeed office two birds one stone I'm
pretty sure has anyone ever done that
that's not an expensive thing just to
shut it down I I think that's what Mitt
Romney used to do really well but like
competitors making money to do it well a
lot of private Equity they'll gut stuff
they're not shutting it down they like
will go far I mean essentially what Elon
did he went and fired three quarters of
the employees I I think honestly that's
probably what a lot of millionaires
actually did because we keep hearing
these stories about hedge funds buying
up news organizations but then
dismantling them and firing people it
may have been just because they were
like these people are cultist weirdos so
we're gonna just destroy their company
yeah that's that's you know man I gotta
be honest if you got I there's some
billionaires out there they want to win
the culture War you just you got you got
to take the risk but here's the problem
nobody these billionaires are like I'm
worth you know 50 billion
I don't want to lose 20 billion dollars
and it's like bro what are you going to
do with that money yeah like you've got
five skyscrapers already you got a yacht
bigger than a city what are you doing
well I guess the like the uh the part of
it is that they don't have that money
it's another company so they're selling
something to buy it right yeah but but
like at a certain point is your net
worth enough yeah it probably just
doesn't they can't even that doesn't
even like register a feeling for them to
just kill 100 company you know like
that's just like I got it I gotta figure
out how to become a billionaire so I can
do well listen I'll for what it's worth
I'll put in like a couple okay yeah all
right I'll put a couple apparently
BuzzFeed part on everybody 437 Million
last year they what yeah but it is and
then what's their negative profit there
was no profit they were negative oh wow
really there was no profits no I'm
pretty sure I don't know that but I know
that no no I'm pretty sure you're right
let me it says um that was a their money
let me uh let me pull it up right here
they're quarter one earnings quarter
four for 2022 was minus two cents okay
2023 no no two cents a share per share
right yeah the profit minus 13 in
quarter 122 is minus 33 cents per share
so you're like you're you're not doing
too well when you're when you're holding
that stuff no but this this is I I've
been talking about this for a while like
where are the ultra rich people to just
buy things
I think they just buy businesses that
like at least can be profitable but but
it's not even the phone no no right
I put up a 90 foot tall billboard of my
rooster in Times Square to make a point
now yeah to break that down the point of
pick up the rooster wasn't just we're
like ah there's a rooster I have a
90-foot picture of my on Times
Square
the joke was actually that people would
see the rooster and then be like what is
this weird thing and then it would the
bigger picture was we've we've taken the
space from you and so we had Lou
gradkowski and Michael Mouse up there
because we were like we want these
anti-establishment anti-war individuals
to be staring down at you so you know
Luke being from New York all of the
powerful Elites who have been chased out
of world economic Forum events or you
know Federal Reserve events are going to
be in Times Square getting a fancy
dinner with their family and they're
going to look up and that's him it's him
and they're gonna you know freak out and
be like how is he on a billboard this
crazy guy so that felt really good and
there's also like a external benefit for
you because like you're a media you know
you're a personality yeah so it's like
it's all you can talk about it and
whatever exactly it's all win-win but my
thing is just like billionaire living in
you know the middle of Idaho but why
like what would you rather own you can
tell one guy a third yacht or to buy
BuzzFeed and then fire everyone third
yeah
[Laughter]
I have a Pacific Ocean one I'd have an
Atlantic Ocean one and then maybe a
Mediterranean one a Mediterranean one
sounds pretty good actually yeah awesome
then Miami for the host my thing is like
if I could own a thing it would be like
a big plaque that says Tim Poole
purchased BuzzFeed and then shut the
company down and fired everybody I mean
here's a good question
we're actually uh renters and we're
behind on that so they got like a 200
million Equity investment from NBC in
2015. uh so are they just like that's
gone in debt yeah yeah probably they
just increase their value because they
kept getting Investments well that's
what this probably SPAC deal was they
they did this uh reverse uh whatever
thing like IPO things so essentially
they could raise money to just keep the
and then the cardigo and you know third
of their costs but they're kind of doing
what America is doing yeah yeah I mean
yeah they can't be making money they
just well I'm pretty sure they're yeah
they're they're in the negative yeah so
I mean if they fire a bunch of people
they might start making money it's got a
fire I think that's kind of what they
were already doing like they were
already firing people and replacing them
with like I mean it's gonna end up like
that scene the end of uh uh Fresh Prince
when it's just
is going to be writing these listicles I
mean you know what I say let's do it I
say let's let's make an AI website where
all the photos and all the all the
articles are just randomly AI generated
nonsense well I've I've been I was
saying this to you guys before but I've
been like trying to figure out use cases
for ad without much success but the one
thing that it is good at is just to like
for funniness is to be like hey uh write
an article about the top 10 uh side
hustles write an article about the top
10 places to visit New York like you can
say stuff like that
easy but it does a really good job I
don't want to pay anybody so can we
automate the process of selection too
like the web design yeah
I don't want a human to prompt anything
prompting anything yeah no I want the AI
to prompt another AI so we need to
program an AI so that and give the
Articles every 24 hours no every hour no
you say think of 10 000 article titles
and then you say feed the ten thousand
and then it runs for another couple
years yeah and then constant a b testing
on your site to just be know like what's
just literal like you know nonsense and
what's good and then it'll train itself
free money there you go that is free
money article does poorly downrank yeah
and then and then they're like the ones
that do well you got more of this and
then it'll just be a Perpetual money
machine but you know what's actually
happening is if you go on Instagram
there's fake women
women are real queens well they'll AI
generate like like 100 images of a fake
woman and then Auto post them and it's
working and they get followers and they
get like that's like only fans and sites
like that right now dudes are like
running them with fake girl profile
pictures they're AI so it's like
basically like it's just a dude giving
money to another dude it's like making
fake I have this it's like amazing girls
they're getting pushed out by dudes yeah
computers thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time